hey guys and welcome to spoiler party
the show where we spoil your favorite
movies in the best way possible I'm Sam
your host and I'm more than a little bit
obsessed with Disney movies so when I
watch Mulan for the first time as an
adult I wasn't surprised that I had more
than a few questions about what I just
watched wait go back go back
so to get some answers to my burning
questions I invited over BuzzFeed's
biggest Mulan fans my favorite song and
I believe I'll make a man out of you
every time it comes on in the club it's
like I'm screaming and I'm top of my
life my favorite song is reflection
because when she hits that high note
you're just like where are you my
favorite song is a girl worth fighting
for it's just really fun to sing my
favorite song is the music that happens
when they're fighting the Huns no no no
no no yeah my favorite song is honored
to us all and my favorite character is
the matchmaker okay let's start with a
lightning round of fun fact mulan trivia
we're gonna play for a prize this
wonderful launcher that's pretty great
okay I'm gonna keep being Sybil I've got
buzzers in front of you I like this
you're gonna slap the buzzer if you
think the statement I say is false
Mushu originally had a song to introduce
himself in the movie but it got cut
because Eddie Murphy didn't really want
to sing
true or false direction can we get an
answer I knew it it's like weird that
like wushu doesn't have a single song in
the entire thing well you know what's
crazy is moo shu actually originally had
three songs but none of them made the
final comment second fact Millan and
Esmeralda from The Hunchback of Notre
Dame actually have the same singing
voice
Sean you go first
yeah in so long yeah she was a Linda's
Rob she was a psycho Saigon yeah I mean
this question was you're right it's
actually Jasmine from Aladdin and Mulan
that share the same singing voice is
long a third fact in Toy Story 2 there's
actually a Mulan Easter egg where a
movie poster is hanging on the wall true
or false
I feel like there probably isn't used to
I get it but I just don't know if it's
Milan okay awesome yeah I'm gonna say
true for this one okay you guys ready
for the answer yeah it is
[Applause]
down a little at Isha that you're not
getting I'll go on Amazon the Milan
poster is actually visible on camera in
lilo and stitch in nanny's bedroom I'm
very proud of us I feel not unlike Milan
who followed her heart we really saved
China today yes and finally did you guys
know that there are some seriously
famous actors and performers in the cast
okay I got this speaking voice of Milano
when singing voice in ilandia salons
ironic is played by baby 1c a voice of
shang-chi is Donny Osmond or three
friends every Fierstein daddy Watson
obvious I'm dropping him last one but I
will move on soon tech oh please you're
bad George Takei is first ancestor the
Emperor is played by Pat Morita thanks
that was James she got oh he was a
legendary actor he was one of the first
interracial kisses screen even for a who
was rocky from Rocky and Bullwinkle
how do you know all this Sean does this
during lunch yeah whenever we eat with
him he pulls out his phone and Google's
legs it's important to know who is
making the content that you're watching
which is why you watch best for you when
Milan first came out I remember seeing
two ad on TV
I was like wait this is a Disney movie
but these people are Asian what the hell
incise ran upstairs to my mom and was
just like there are Asians in the Disney
movie and then home was like what's the
wrong kind of Asian we're gentlemen
these are not changed no it doesn't
matter and then my grandma took me to
the Torrence Galleria to see it but we
relate so we went is memory is so vivid
we stepped into the theater and she was
just waking up in four tents about to
like eat the food and health to camp
remember being like real disappointed
and then my grandma was just like you
know what I should stay so we stayed in
the theater and watch that movie one and
a half times it just imagine little
Shawn just being so excited yeah now I'm
not excited about anything
there are some fascinating fan theories
about Mulan and one of the biggest fan
theories that move on herself is the
great stone dragon
you know how mushas whole purpose is to
ring the gong to wake up the guardians
and ancestors but he can't wake up the
dragon if the stone dragon is really
m.i.a then why does the Dragons likeness
show up in so many shots leading up to
her running away from home maybe this is
the story of how he became maybe it was
that stone dragon was always there we
just never knew because it never
manifested or out there do we think
father LAN is actually the great stone
dragon stone dragon is meant to protect
the family she protected her family she
protected China yeah which is her family
oh that's i heard according to Chinese
mythology that dragons can control the
weather
Mulan actually causes an avalanche while
they're fighting and when she's getting
super emotional by her dad leaving she's
sitting under the stone dragon and it's
raining while she's crying
don't make that movie so much more he
knows already my talks a shark has a
thought what if to flip it the dragon
represents the traditional order of the
family yeah I'm like by LaVon leaving
the house
it's her appending that tradition and
with that the crumbling of the statue
listen father I like about tradition
getting torn down but then her
ultimately using it in a new way
take a dragon cannon for example she is
told to use it in one way but instead
she uses it in a different way and that
makes all the difference
she was China this is like sparknotes
symbolism hacks USC communications class
of 2010
fan theory number two is Li Shan the
first queer Disney Prince oh yeah you
guys I've even in the first I mean some
of them could have been in the closet we
just didn't know there's a lot of fan
theories that we Shang
bisexual let's look at the evidence just
look at these tender moments between li
Shang and we want those eyes now find
that Paul wait that needs to be a meme
on Twitter right now it will be and it
would explain Li Jiang's absolute look
of betrayal when he finds out me wand
was a woman my fear when Milan's hair we
should I do and as soon as we found out
she's a woman
her hair is automatically down his hair
is down he's a woman what really makes
any changes guys yeah it's like a Clark
Kent thing
who is the Superman no one knows I'm
wearing glasses to be fair back in the
day well in Chinese era Dynasty fighting
times all the men's hair was actually
long so they had to put it up Oh Stacy
with the fact he was a good I feel like
if everyone hadn't been around his
reaction would have been so much more
different I feel like he had to put on a
show you know it's all about that toxic
masculinity if I was there I'd be like
Sheng you just came out okay it's okay
we all get here when Mulan sings the
song reflection the lyrics seemed to
speak specifically to the experience of
being unable to come out to one's family
and feeling tired at having pretended
for so long
truly to be myself I would break my
family's heart did you guys see that or
recognize that the first time that you
saw the movie or even times afterward
that's kind of like a Disney thing on
the whole so there's actually a type of
song they have in every movie called the
iron want song and so it like Little
Mermaid
it's where the people all says I want to
be an ice queen it connects with the
audience because we all have something
inside of us that we want to express we
want to explore more and sometimes it's
being gay this became kind of like a
gate anthem almost when a song came out
a lot of people were like oh my gosh
like that's exactly how I feel that this
movie is really about recognizing the
limits of gender whether it's the
matchmaker and like that sequence and
the way that that's holding her back
from her full potential or Shang's like
talking masculinity holding him back
from his like accepting gender fluidity
into his ancient Chinese army these
gender constructions are all [ __ ] and
we need to move beyond them also isn't
it a little bit ironic that in order to
save China the rest of the Shang's army
has to dress in drag so that brings us
to the big question for this topic is
Mulan the queerest Disney movie ever I
think it's a good I think it's pretty
gay yeah it's a gay for me sure yeah
it's pretty gay so that's gay games
across the board we're running at a time
but I still have a lot of unanswered
questions I need to know how Mulan got
her makeup off in one perfect swipe
that's really great question when I
think she's like one swollen looking you
know I end up looking like the
matchmaker honestly I still think the
makeup maneuver is more impressive than
her saving all of China
how does grandmother foie not have her
own spin-off movie I wanna see wasn't
ancestors
like wrecking havoc emulators living her
best life find the key finding a man or
many more many families she's got her
man during all the training scenes it
seems like there are dozens of troops
working under li Shang but as they move
their way to the capital city they get
less and less until there's under ten
what happened to all of them it's more
people dying me I'm sorry but this is a
Disney movie best way they didn't die on
screen you know how there was like
explosions in the snow and people got
buried that was then too but those are
less men for grandmother fought a thirst
after well they'll be in the afterlife
so I got another question is Mulan the
most badass Disney Princess yes she were
marketing purposes she is we gotta sell
the toys so she's a princess today
pretty much okay guys I saved the best
one for last
are there enough scenes with we Shang
shirtless I'm gonna give you guys bonus
points if I can guess how many scenes he
is shirtless in the movie training
sequence can count as multiple scenes we
gotta say 12 I'm gonna say eight I'm
gonna go Tim okay
fourteen feet and you know what I'm
gonna buzz in I still don't think that's
enough can you imagine if li Shang was
an Instagram model you know every pic
will get first Travis MySpace he's got
one Twitter account for each of his pack
so Stacey was closest with twelve fiends
because li Shang had his shirt off you
get to put the long shirt for saying
other winners a t-shirt that you're not
getting
he knew the entire freakin imbd listen
they're not worth it okay they're not
worth it we'll go on Amazon you're not
getting your money back on that round
two you know justice I'm gonna
Disneyland
okay guys thank you so much for joining
us this has been spoiler party move on
edition be sure to tell us in the
comments below which movie you want us
to spoil next and subscribe to our
Channel
[Music]